so when you go out on the road from
doing that stuff and come back as soon
as I got in my in my car did hit the
highway like oh my god it's I'm never
leaving yeah it's the bad this is home
it's the best
well it's 73 73 degrees and and bright
sunshine I mean is is everything on fire
yeah we'll get through this we'll figure
this out yeah yeah it's all good as
always can get through the fire I mean
[ __ ] happens and it's like it's all good
baby long as it's not shining I got the
beach I heard I heard they think bum
sided those fires have you heard that
yeah it was a homeless encounter which
is why I always say we have to get a
kill you got if they don't have a time
just not to look I'm sure some are very
nice people for all hobos just need
simply need to die I'm sorry good yeah
I'm not even trying to be a dish that's
you Bochy and they're not really on this
one no especially if they look cold
we killing yeah but but we do it humane
Lee no you just kind of yeah throw
jellyfish on ya or just a high-powered
rifle but you know what I mean I mean
just because we can't have fires like
listen you've seen the movie the purge I
agree with that well I think you just go
after the bum that's once a year check
hard bum fast
we call it pump fest and just it's free
rein you have a home nope dick dude you
guys ready to go on a bum run and wait
but we have teams we have like cool
t-shirts now i bono go it's hope oh no
go today guys hobo no go the bum down
we're gonna called the bum down the bum
down so [ __ ] I'm down ah dude why'd we
do just this we just [ __ ] lost
oh my bad that's right a bad some
homeless guy list applaud cuz like [ __ ]
you guys man I've been a longtime
listener you know I make very little
money but the money I make I have a
[ __ ] cell phone and I listen to
podcasts pass the time and [ __ ] you time
I was sitting eating breakfast in New
York City and the guy comes in a
handsome guy and look like a biker and
he's like he's like I'll get the same
thing I'll get that scrambled eggs
please and bacon would be great and good
idea that Oh that'd be great thank you
so much man oh no this is perfect
I'd love a spread you know again make an
espresso it's gonna get a coffee but
lets me you know I can let's make it
both thanks man appreciate
I'm a great guy mustache kinda handsome
mouths like that handsome young kind of
you know 40-some a B maybe 40 but
handsome and big bro kind of a strapping
young man have a conversation with him
talking
he's eating basically the same thing I'm
eating so I was like loved eating the
same kind of food and I said I said what
do you do I'm an actor I recognize you
yeah yeah la I lived in LA for a long
time I came out here about eight months
ago had a motorcycle accident I was like
[ __ ] it and just came out I go ok
motorcycle accident you ride a bike
because I did I did yeah and he sounds
good good good on you man how's that I
was so acting at that tough gig and
stand-up and great and I said what are
you doing cuz you know don't laugh but I
am I I set out piece of cardboard and I
basically Panhandle because they make an
average of 57 dollars a day I've
averaged it out Wow Wow yeah and then it
says [ __ ] thing was so normal but I
was I was like now I gotta fight it
might be crazy look crazy I go I go but
you had the motorcycle accident what
what did you do that was it that was it
for me I was here they go but but it
wasn't it why didn't you just you know I
don't know fix the bike I couldn't my
favorite I was finished
it was snappin I know hey just don't
laugh but don't laugh I was like you
just went to the dark side brother oh
okay so we're not able to maintain this
mood sometimes you're not able to
maintain no it's just the phase that
yesterday whether he's back in the news
so he was saying that it was either a
periscope the article say was on
periscope but it look like a this day in
age it looked like Instagram life so he
was saying to the fans that the UFC
called him not too long ago that they
want him back and then he could actually
make a billion dollars there maybe do a
few fights there I feel sick I feel
physically ill when I see this again I
just talked about how the UFC the
ratings are all-time low because it's
the entertainment era and they want to
book these guys that at the time will
get a huge amount of views but in
overall grant schema of the company and
the in the fights and the game plan it's
getting up screw Nia so you got to sleep
in the bay that bed you're gonna lay in
how many times are going to make this
bad Floyd Mayweather fighting in the UFC
is the biggest crock of [ __ ] that they
could possibly make it's this ridiculous
at what point do we stop this
I heard Brad Pitt's there was a mean
left hook you want to book him I heard
he's down to fight in Boston I heard
George Clooney makes helmet tequila you
want to book him to like win when do we
stop I guarantee you George Clooney and
Brad Pitt will be huge pay-per-view
gainers huge stars go and book them man
her dr. Phil scan hell of a double-leg
gonna book him so at what point do we
stop doing this [ __ ] weird why would
you sign for we've made with her and
also billion dollars you ain't making a
billion dollars in the UFC because
what's gonna happen is everyone's gonna
tune in once and you're gonna get ankle
picked and choked out in 30 seconds then
after that it's over that that ship has
sailed
no one wants to see that either man I
highly doubt they've offered them that
money to do you think they actually
talked to him about is that true do you
think that is such a [ __ ] show I don't
think so
oh you know what I I'm gonna pretend
that they do I'm gonna pretend WME is it
so desperate for money and to make up
that 400 million dollar not that they
have to cover that they're sorry bill
four billion or the [ __ ] two billion
that they don't they're not so desperate
to get money that they're gonna start
doing stuff like this I hope I hope it's
no he's worried if you get a friend an
animal for a gift cuz how do you know
they're you know you don't want that
they go into
Todd Feldman's house right all right my
agent and he has these cats and my girl
loves cats
but this oh my god loves cats I'm
allergic to him oh you are I'm super
allergic to him and when I was a kid we
had to get rid of him cuz so allergic to
him we went to the doctor cuz my
allergies were there all the time my
dad's like we just don't understand like
it's winter he has allergies and the
doctors do you have an animal in the
house money goes oh we did just we had
cats about a year ago so it's the cat
he's solution let me do a little math
here two cats yeah and then he's like
anything else is there anything else you
guys Nene's like cats get really cat
yeah so we got really cared I'd be the
cat's well I'm talking about like
everyday my eyes would be swollen shut
like that my office Tara but I wanted
the cat so bad was an animal lover just
pretend it was something else
yeah and I told Jo she won't believe me
she's like you're just full of [ __ ] you
just don't want a cat like I'm telling
you I'm allergic so you know you're not
like I swear to God much to the cat she
said no you're not like all right I took
the cat rubbed his face way like this it
sure enough by dinner looks like a good
guys are okay yeah yeah I am I'm super
allergic to him it I guess you can get a
shot these days though I guess my wife
for your ballsack here's my wife for
years would around Christmas she would
have the worst allergies couldn't figure
it out configure it was the Christmas
tree pine my news killer that's it and
she's from Denver
they're everywhere I know that's
interesting